hi i'm ayo and i'm a private chef but
more importantly than that i
love lasagna if meat there's cheese
pasta what's not to like you're used to
seeing me on dollar dish
and being forced to cook things with no
budget whatsoever
but today tasty has let go of the reins
and i get to make
three kinds of lasagna one that takes
six minutes
one that takes 60 minutes and one that's
going to take me
six hours i got a budget y'all all right
so
let's get into it so this is our six
minute microwave lasagna
not gonna lie i had a lot of attitude
about this girl not really into the
whole mug cooking thing
but if you are a lasagna head like me
and you just need your fix
and a pinch this is the way to go so for
our first step we're going to use these
oven ready lasagna sheets basically what
you want to do is break your lasagna
into pieces that will fit into whatever
mug you're using
so for my mug i'm going to break my
little halves
into more halves and maybe one more half
so i'm just going to continue breaking
up my pasta so then i'm going to add
them to this microwave
safe bowl and i'm going to cover them in
about a cup and a half of water and cook
them for three minutes
you want to make sure you cover your
noodles completely now i'm gonna go put
these in the microwave for three minutes
now i'm gonna strain them you should be
really careful because the bowl is
probably like very hot so for our next
step we're just gonna make a really
quick ricotta filling so i'm gonna add
my spinach to my ricotta i'm just going
to give this a quick stir
and now all we have to do is assemble so
first we have
tablespoon of marinara i spread it
around i have my microwave noodles
and i just want to create like as even a
layer as possible
so you can get a little bit of noodle in
everybody and then our ricotta mixture
you spread it around so now it's time to
add our cheese i'm really into the
italian blend because it's a lot of bang
for your buck there's a lot of different
cheeses there's romano there's parmesan
there's some mozzarella a little bit of
everything in one bite
and then we just keep on layering
marinara noodle
ricotta cheese marinara noodle
ricotta surprise cheese it's kind of
like singing hakuna matata
marinara pasta ricotta cheese and we
definitely want to end on cheese because
we want the top of this to be like
super ooey gooey so obviously this is
probably gonna take you more than six
minutes to put it together
but it takes six minutes to cook so now
i'm gonna take this to the microwave for
three more minutes so it's been
microwaved and i'm not gonna lie
it smells pretty good i'm a little
surprised so i'm gonna tear up some
pieces of fresh basil
and just put them right on the top a
little color a little herb
i really like basil so then i'm also
going to add
more cheese because what does lasagna
always need
more cheese and then finally i'm going
to add a little bit of dried basil
across the top and this is totally
optional but y'all know i like colors so
this is just me being extra time to
taste it
cheese pull
it's actually pretty good it is really
shocking how tender those noodles get in
six minutes
it's cheesy you taste it you would not
think if anything else this is lasagna
and it's good
six minutes who knew so now we're
getting into our 60-minute lasagna we're
gonna make roll-ups because they're
super cute
they're really tasty and also
individually portioned so basically we
want to be able to get a hearty meal on
the table
very quickly also our roll-ups are going
to cook a lot faster than the
traditional layering method so we're
going to add our onions to a hot pan
with a little bit of olive oil and just
cook them until they're softened
about five to six minutes so after my
onions have softened i'm just going to
add my fresh thyme
and i'm going to add my minced garlic
i'm just going to cook them until
fragrant about one minute
i can smell them so now i'm going to add
my sausage
when you add your sausage you want to
make sure you break it up into very
small pieces for your sauce
i use italian sausage because even
though we're making a little bit faster
i wanted to keep it as
close to tradition as possible okay so
our sausage is cooked
so now i'm going to add our jar of
marinara sauce and if you really want to
create you know a good
depth of flavor in a short amount of
time you want to really invest in a good
jar of marinara sauce i'm just going to
let this simmer for about five minutes
so now it's probably the easiest step of
our whole process which is just make
your noodles i'm going to add a little
bit of salt to my boiling pasta water
you want to have this water at a rolling
boil
and get your noodles done as fast as
possible you also want to cook them
about two minutes less than the package
directions
because we're also gonna put them in the
oven i know a lot of you are about to be
upset with me
brace yourselves i am going to add olive
oil
to the pot i'm aware that this is a
cardinal sin
but because we're doing roll-ups it's
just necessary to break some rules
we do not want the lasagna noodles to
stick together as we roll them up
okay so our noodles are looking good and
i'm just going to strain them
over a bowl or over your sink if you're
at home over your sink for those of you
who are freaking out about the oil in
the pot prepare to be upset again we are
making a more americanized version of
lasagna this time so we're using ricotta
for our filling i'm going to be adding
spinach
mozzarella parmesan basil parsley
and egg yolks the egg yolks are to bind
our filling together
so when we roll it up and put in the
oven everything holds together
so the ricotta filling is actually my
personal favorite
which i'm sure right about now the other
chefs in the community are like what
i prefer ricotta to the bechamel because
i like the texture it gives it it's a it
feels like a harder your feeling
all right and now we are just going to
mix it up and then i'm going to season
it up just a little
i'm going to add a little bit of pepper
yeah
our filling's done and we have our
casserole dish so now i'm gonna add
about a cup of the sauce to cover the
bottom
of our casserole pan you just want to
get a thin layer at the bottom to
prevent our noodles from sticking
so now it's time for the fun part i'm
going to add about a half cup of the
ricotta filling to each of my lavagna
noodles
i feel like there's no real special way
to do this you know you just can't be
shy you just get in there
so i'm going to use this offset spatula
just to smooth it out a little
one tip i do have for this process is
when you're filling it with your ricotta
filling
i leave just a little lip at the end so
when i close up my lasagna roll up it
fits tight to the last part
also as we roll our noodles it's going
to push the filling forward a little bit
so you're just giving yourself a little
bit of extra room to catch that extra
filling oh my god so cute
so this is what you're looking for you
want there to be filling you want it to
be visible but you don't want it leaking
out of your noodle and now i'm just
gonna set it in my pan so i'm just gonna
repeat this process seven more times
now we're gonna top it with some sauce
and some more cheese
and for aesthetic purposes i'm really
big on going
across the top of them so now i'm gonna
top my roll-ups with
obviously more cheese my favorite part
of lasagna is definitely the cheese you
would think
it would be the pasta because you know
southern girl southern carbs but no
i love grated parmesan cheese it's like
happy little snowfall
all right so these look great i'm gonna
go put these in the oven at 400 degrees
for 20 minutes
okay so our lasagna rolls are out of the
oven and this smells
incredible and now it's time
this is good it's really easy it's
definitely something my mom can make
y'all know beer can't cook so that is a
testament to how simple this
is if you book me the next lasagna
is what you would get something that
takes time something that has
multiple layers of flavor so stick
around for the six
hour lasagna so this lasagna has all the
traditional flavors
we're gonna make it a little extra we're
gonna do ten layers because if you're
gonna spend six hours making it why not
make it epic right so our first step is
gonna be
adding a little olive oil to our pan and
we're gonna cook
our pancetta and this is going to be the
beginning of our bolognese when you're
rendering the pancetta which is just
fancy thick cut bacon
you really want to make sure you get it
nice and crispy and get all of the fat
out of it
and then we're going to cook all of our
veggies in that fat
so this is the first step in really
layering that depth of flavor
all right so my pancetta is nice and
crisp
look at that that golden brown
deliciousness i'm going to remove the
pancetta from the pan while we cook
our mirepoix basically you want to take
the meat out so it doesn't keep cooking
and get too crispy
you still want all the fat and flavor
that it left in the bottom of the pan
so now i'm going to add my onions
carrots
celery which are the three components of
a mirepoix
i'm gonna add my thyme and my garlic and
we're just gonna cook these for a little
while and coat them in
all that fat and i'm just going to saute
these until soft
next step is adding our protein a big
thing for me when doing italian food is
to make sure you have the right ratio of
like neediness to fat
so we are using a half pound of ground
pork
and a half pound of ground beef i feel
like pork
has more flavor and is very fatty and
then beef is very
meaty so the pork and the beets mixed
together just gives you the best of both
worlds
so we're just looking for this to get
brown and give us those good crusty bits
on the bottom of the pan
so now our meat has browned and it's
time to deglaze
the point of deglazing is just get
anything that may have been left over
around the pan
and basically you're just going to add
about a cup of wine
once it has reduced by about half you
won't smell the liquor anymore
and you want to make sure when you're
deglazing you're scraping up like any
brown bits on the side
i believe in french it's called the fond
you just want to
get it into your sauce every little bit
of flavor helps so now we're going to
move on to the tomatoes this is actually
a trick i learned from
an italian chef that i used to work with
basically giving you the feel of like
real slow cooked crushed tomatoes but
from a can
so basically what you want to do is take
your whole peeled tomato
and just squish it in your hand just
really get in there
love it and that's it and basically it
creates like a chunkier version
of the typical crushed tomato sauce
that's my last one
and we have this beautiful chunky tomato
sauce
now i'm going to add them to my meat
mixture the wine has reduced
and it looks ready to go i'm just going
to mix these in
and then i am going to add one cup milk
and one cup chicken stock
and as this reduces your chicken stock
is gonna develop this
really rich flavor so we're gonna let
this go low and slow
and really come together over the course
of the next three hours
so let's leave this and begin working on
our pasta noodles
okay so now we're gonna add our flour to
the mixing bowl
and i'm gonna add my salt and basically
we're just gonna turn the mixture on for
like 10 seconds to incorporate the salt
and the flour
and now i'm going to add my eggs and
we're going to let this go
for about five minutes until it gets
smooth and elastic
okay this pasta is done so i'm gonna
wrap this in plastic
and let it rest for about an hour okay
my pasta is done
she's rested and now i'm gonna cut this
dough ball into six pieces
and roll them through our poster
extruder and what you want to do is
start on your widest setting
and just keep processing it through
until you get to
either your smallest or second smallest
setting what you want is some
paper thin sheets of pasta i will say
the thinner it gets the more gentle you
kind of need to be with it
okay so this one's looking really good
i'm gonna repeat this process about six
more times
and then i'm gonna just very quickly
cook these in boiling water and then
we'll move on to our bechamel a bechamel
is actually one of the mother sauces
it's one of the
first things you learn in culinary
school and what it is is
a really good milky base to carry on a
lot of other flavors
mostly cheese and when you add cheese to
it it's actually called a mornay sauce
so the first thing we are going to do to
get our bechamel sauce together
is melt this butter and i'm gonna whisk
in this flour
i just want to cook this enough to get
that raw flour taste out of it
about three or four minutes now we're
going to add our milk the reason you
want your milk to be room temperature
is because when it's cold there's more
chances for your root to get
chunky because we want like a nice
creamy sauce nobody wants a mouthful of
like flour and butter and i'm just going
to let this go
until it starts to thicken up you don't
want to rush this process
because you do not want to scald the
milk scalding the milk means you cook it
on too high
and it burns at the bottom and there's
no fixing it i'm also going to add some
fresh
nutmeg to this any sauce i make with
like a milk base
or a significant amount of cheese i
always give it a pinch of nutmeg for
extra flavor so we're almost there but
we want this to be pretty thick because
remember we being extra
so we're doing 10 layers so it needs to
be thick enough to sustain those layers
you know so you want to get to
almost a pudding like consistency it
needs to be pretty
pretty thick okay this is looking good
and now it is time to build this
epic 10 layer lasagna so the first thing
we're going to do
is add some sauce to the bottom of our
pan we're just going to do one
even layer across the bottom and after
our sauce
we're going to add our noodles remember
we made these ourselves so it's okay if
the noodles go up the sides of your pan
a little
or you can cut them on top of our
noodles we're going to do another layer
of sauce with some parmesan
i'm just going to give it a nice
sprinkle some of the cheese in there
and now we're going to add another layer
of noodles after this layer of noodle
i'm going to add in my bechamel the
sauce came out amazing
and now i'm going to add my mozzarella
cheese and then we're gonna do
another layer of noodles so now we're
just gonna repeat this process
four more times all right and last but
not least
we're going to top this beauty with
fresh
mozzarella it does not get more italian
and more extra than fresh mozzarella
this is probably my favorite part i'm
also gonna add just a little bit more
parmesan cheese
i really want the top to be like cheesy
and gooey and melty
and i'm just going to cover it in a
layer of white all right i'm going to
put this lasagna in the oven at 350
degrees for one hour cover it for the
first 30 minutes and then
uncover for the last 30 minutes because
i really want the cheese to get brown
let's do it all right this looks good
and i am what it would be so excited
because this
is my personal favorite part i'm going
to just tear some pieces of fresh basil
and use them as our garnish this thing
smells
amazing it smells like six hours worth
of love and labor
here we go the moment of truth oh that's
what i'm talking about
look at that see how many extra pays off
oh my god this looks
amazing i mean i made the recipe so you
know
let's try it oh my god
this was so worth six hours you get so
much more
like than the other two you taste all
the work you put into the bechamel
a little bit of nutmeg that little
secret nuttiness there's so much flavor
in the sauce
this one is definitely my favorite but
you know i like a little extra so today
we made a six minute a 60 minute and a
six hour lasagna so whether you're just
cooking a little meal for one or feeding
a crowd you
always have time for lasagna thank you
guys so much for watching my video
please encourage tasty to give me more
things with the budget
and i will see you next time
[Music]
you